This youngster was banned
from performing
at his
first grade talent show
because his act was deemed
too inappropriate.
Now as a fellow artist
I will not stand for censorship.
So making his television
debut. Please welcome Eric.
Thanks Mr. Tosh here's my
talent.
Is that real?
Oh!
How is that even possible?
Jesus.
Smell it.
I can't believe you farted like
that. How?
Get this girl a show
on Comedy Central now.
I think we finally solve
the riddle
of why hospital gowns
are open in the back.
Quick! Pull the covers
over your wife's head.
I'm dreaming
of a weighty tidy Christmas.
At least fart in them with
care.
I'm guessing
too much fruitcake.
Wake up!
Unfortunately we can
only save your mustache
and your butthole.
Paul Flart is dead.
From this day on you
will simply be known
as Roboflart.
A lean mean ass-rippin' machine.
Well, not that lean.
It'll take you a while
to get used to it.
That's an unarmed black man.
You're gonna make
one hell of a cop.
I'll just say
he was holding a knife.
You have the right
to remain silent.
But deadly.
Might want to
change his name to Roboshart.
He didn't deserve to get
thrown under the fart bus
so we brought him out to L.A.
to clear the air.
In this week's Web redemption.
That is not
what it looked like.
I just enjoy spanking
kids with a paddle.
Now get in here fartsy.